so i guess i'm an orthodox christian but
if i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to bet on islam
or near a mosque i feel energy that i
i'm at peace with
i might convert to islam right now
[Music]
now the majority of you got acquainted
with my next guest emory andrew tate
who's a four-time kickboxing world
champion
commentator and businessman entrepreneur
when his video went viral in the muslim
world people were emailing us the video
and forwarded to me actually on whatsapp
saying you got to get this guy on the
show so here we go welcome welcome
andrew tate how you doing my brother i'm
good my friend i'm good sorry for the
the delay in my appearance but you know
i made it in the end that's the most
important thing very nice thank you for
accepting an invitation
so let's start off with it see they got
to see this um
you're in this car now was it uh
familiarize me with some of these uh
this uh
this brand this it says on the steering
wheel e hold on what are the people
seeing here
and that's
that's me in dubai just you know living
the life my friend living the life in
dubai so uh i'm there a lot i'm there
often
and uh my that's actually the place my
place i stay it's right opposite the
mosque so
beautiful do you do you actually if you
don't mind me do you know the words what
where what are being said when you hear
their thoughts since you hear it so so
often there
no so i think you and i first started
speaking after it was actually a video
before this video i believe i was on a
podcast and i was explaining
how much respect i have for the
faith of islam
and how it's a faith which is formidable
and it's a faith that needs to be
respected if somebody says look
the uh the muslims are angry at you then
it matters but if someone says the
christians are angry at you nobody cares
anymore right and this is what i was
trying to say i have a lot of respect
for the faith i'm not a practicing
muslim however i do have absolute
respect for it so no i don't understand
the words i didn't i didn't uh
i don't know what it's saying it's
beautiful but please tell me i'd love to
know yeah that's what i love to do is
you know because it's so beautiful but
then actually you appreciate it even
more you know like if you're telling
somebody you're also you speak romanian
uh
a little bit yeah i speak a little bit
romanian but i'm american originally hi
yeah you're from chicago no correct i'm
from chicago but i live in romania now
which is
it's kind of crazy like my my whole
religious experience my whole religious
journey is i prefer to spend time in the
most religious places on earth i think
they're the best places to be romania is
very it's the opposite of tobias
extremely orthodox christian it's
actually the most christian country in
the world so i spend most of my time
between dubai which is you know very
overtly uh muslim and then i come to
back to romania which is very overtly
christian but both of them have strong
faith and i think a lot of the problems
with the world today is that the west is
lacking faith and i don't like being
around i don't like being in agnostic or
atheistic societies anymore i try to
avoid them if possible so in sha log
which means god willing after you and
i'll define these turns as we go along
after you take your maybe inshallah in
the future you take your shahada or
maybe even on the show you can end up in
the most holiest place in mecca since
you like being around the most religious
places well hey absolutely i mean like i
said my own personal journey it's it's i
think it's taking a little bit of time i
i know
um people often ask me what religion are
you and it's hard for me to answer that
specifically when i am in dubai or near
a mosque i feel an energy that i i'm at
peace with and i enjoy wow but i can't
say it's not true also about particular
churches here in romania so
for for now all i know is i need to be a
good person um and and that's what i'm
trying to do but i have and i stated it
in the last podcast before people often
ask me you know which religion do you
when they ask me which which religion i
am i make it very clear the religion i
have the most respect for is islam
it's not even close it has to be
uh so just for educational purposes i
like to go ahead and just share with
people when you hear this and you'll
probably appreciate it more what
the person is saying is to call the
prayers god is the greatest god is the
greatest there's no god but the one god
there's nothing worthy of worship but
god uh come to prayer come to success
and
there's nothing worthy of worship except
god and muhammad is the final messenger
this is basically in a nutshell what the
meaning is behind it so
that that seems pretty reasonable yeah i
mean yeah and that and that would
automatically include jesus and all the
preceding messengers that came because
when you take this this testimony this
shahadah right away it doesn't exclude
jesus and this is i don't know if you've
already learned by now that it's a
pillar it's actually
the belief in jesus is something that
every muslim has to love and revere
jesus as a mighty messenger otherwise
you can you exit islam yeah it's
actually amazing how in many ways like
you're saying jesus is one part of it
but in many ways obviously there's key
differences but in many ways there's a
lot of similarities and it's kind of
funny to me whereas christianity in the
modern world has become such a laughing
stock and it has been because people
don't practice it in any kind of strict
way anymore really and people say oh you
know islam so strict and i say look a
lot of the rules of islam are also in
the in the bible you just you're a
christian who's never read it like
you've never read your own bible you
don't you don't know what your own rules
are so it's amazing how similar a lot of
the tenants of the two religions are
it's just islam and muslims are the last
people who take it seriously and
practice it in a way it should be
practiced and respect it
and that's why i think i first kind of
went viral
in the islamic world when i said look
i have so much respect for muslims as a
whole in the way they view their faith
and how seriously they take it i don't
understand why you have these girls who
call themselves christians and they're
drinking on saturday night meeting boys
doing whatever and then going to church
on the next day i don't that doesn't
feel real to me does that make sense
yeah absolutely
i want to get into that video now and
take some clips from it and you can
watch yourself i was going to do a
breakdown of this but i said why not
have the man on himself you can do a
breakdown do a breakdown while i'm here
i'd love to hear it bro you can do a
breakdown here let's go ahead you'll
help me with it islam fixes a lot of the
problems that men are currently facing
the problems we're discussing on this
show islam fixes all of them
right that's the first thing about islam
and i'm not a muslim right if i had to
choose a religion i would because i live
in an orthodox christian country i go to
the orthodox christian church i donate
twenty thousand dollars a month to the
church in the country i live in the
church the church in romania is very
powerful and i like having church
friends so i give them a lot of money
right so i guess i'm an orthodox
christian but
if i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to bet on this mom
that's deep
what do you think what do you think of
my uh my analysis i love it i mean this
is uh you you actually uh did you have a
lot of muslims contacted you after this
i mean they were sharing i was getting
this video from from
my team from on whatsapp all over the
place uh
yeah i was getting yeah crazy messages
all over over instagram lots and lots of
messages and i think a lot of people
were very surprised by what i said but
it's very true i mean what i say
is
the islamic faith and i've said it
already on this podcast it's taken
seriously it's respected by its its
tenants and it's very much like you know
if i
let me given uh an analogy if you don't
respect your own house if you walk into
somebody's house and it's a and it's a
mess you're not gonna worry about making
a mess or about cleaning up after
yourself or leaving a cup on the coffee
table right but if you walk into
someone's house and it's pristine then
you're gonna be very very concerned
about making a mess and they have
muslims have so much respect for
themselves that people automatically
respect the religion as a whole whereas
christians don't and this is the thing
we talk about things having longevity we
talk about
things lasting into the future
especially religions as a whole if you
become tolerant of everything to the
point where like christianity is now
where they say oh we're tolerant well if
you're so tolerant you ignore your own
book
then what are you
do do you know where i'm coming from and
that's why i have so much faith uh sorry
so much respect for the islamic faith
and that's why it's the one i would bet
on and when i say bet on i mean i can i
know muslims will be here in 100 years
what does what does christian mean today
very little what's it going to mean in
100 years
nothing
like let's be honest right so
that's also another really interesting
way to look at it because then i start
to look at things and say okay well you
have to choose which religion or which
faith you believe is
is the true faith but if one faith
survives and the other faith is
annihilated in real time that tells you
a lot as well doesn't it doesn't that
tell you a lot absolutely so um it's
really interesting for me it's it's like
i have not made any kind of final
decisions etc but i try and analyze
things from a very very
logical perspective i know god exists
and then you go oh say okay god exists
and there's all these different
interpretations of god as such but the
only one i see which has a warrior class
that people fear
is islam that's that's the only one
there is
let's uh let's contin to continue on
here
respect that about them i respect that
that's an amazing thing about them right
and the third point is and i've been all
around the world
some of the best countries in the world
today are the first world muslim nations
yeah qatar
you can go to qatar you can fall asleep
with a million dollars on your lap in
the middle of the street nothing's going
to happen saudi arabia if you're gonna
go to saudi nothing will happen you can
go dubai uae nothing they leave their
cars parked with the with the kids
inside it's so safe wow you know we
often hear andrew
you know people end up
hearing that oh if you go out to that
part of the world they're going to chop
your head off they
they create this fear and anxiety you
know for people living in america but
now you're talking about something
totally the antithesis today you're
talking about so safe and you said
something that if you you could fall
asleep in qatar with a million dollars
on your lap literally
and it'd still be there absolutely and
and that's the thing yeah you can get
yourself in a lot of trouble in those
countries if you turn up and disrespect
the country as a whole but why should
and why would you do that right if you
turn off and you show the respect the
appropriate respect you're not going to
have trouble in these places at all all
of the trouble that exists in the west
the general i often say like
it's kind of strange when you discuss
crimes as a whole right it's kind of
interesting to me that the western
democracies have always sold this lie
that
you're safe from the government if it's
a democracy well that's not true that's
been proven in real time recently right
canada has proved that australia's
proved that america's prove that so
you're never safe from your government
so democracy as a whole is no safer to
exist under than
a kingdom
uh like the kingdom of saudi arabia or a
dictatorship there's you're no safer
under a democracy so we can remove that
element the whole idea that they're not
democratic because democracy doesn't
provide anything or or or help anything
in terms of safety from the government
but what a democracy does do is cause so
much fraction and so much disintegration
amongst the society that now you have to
not only fear your government you have
to fear the normal people on the street
it's crazy i read yesterday in la
they're telling people no longer to wear
jewelry they're advertising on the news
don't wear jewelry wow that's incredible
and this is one this is the richest
country in the world right and you go to
these poor countries these poor
countries but because people like we
just discussed because people are
religious because people have a higher
purpose because they see beyond the
material goods of only this world it's a
very safe place to be i've been to these
places and i feel completely perfectly
safe yes of course i could get my hand
chopped off if i'm an idiot but why but
but i would rather exist in a society
where i know the lines and i know the
boundaries and i know how i get myself
in trouble and not do it that exist in
new york city where i can be obeying the
law and just be in the wrong place at
the wrong time and get a drive-by you
know what i'm saying absolutely these
places are absolutely safe and they're
safe because they've maintained
they've maintained the basic structure
of family the basic structure and the
basic structure that's all it is when
you maintain the basic structure of
family you maintain the basic structure
of society yep and and that's all it is
right
and and it's kind of amazing as well
in first world muslim nations when you
maintain the
the family structure people also don't
want to bring shame upon their family so
the family do a lot of policing they
don't want to have a member of their
family that's out there committing crime
right so like the west is broken on so
many levels and that's what i was kind
of saying in that video is that
a lot of the problems are fixed by islam
as a whole and and the first world
muslim nations are proof of it i think a
lot of people think that muslim
countries are dangerous because of a lot
of the war in the middle east but the
war in the middle east is propagated by
the west anyway that's again that's
america's fault so yeah
so
you know it's it's it's it's crazy
really
how did you feel would you feel welcome
obviously you've been there for a long
time dubai how did you feel now with the
community people welcoming the hospital
hospitality etc
it's yeah it's amazing like dubai is the
least
racist place on the planet i think 90 of
the people there from other places you
can be black white new filipinos are
there vietnamese are there everyone's
there from everywhere americans
everyone's there it's amazing that you
have a city which is statistically so
safe with all these different people
from all these different places right
and they've done that by just
maintaining some kind of social cohesion
you can't have degeneracy all around you
24 7 without degenerating as a person
right and that's what's happened in the
western world
to a degree christianity used to keep
the western world in check but the
christianity's become so weak it doesn't
mean anything anymore and we're living
in a situation now where if you want to
go somewhere where you know that you can
exist in a wholesome environment i mean
that when you go outside you're going to
see families man woman some children
it's going to be very fairly wholesome
you're not seeing a degeneracy you're
not going to see anything strange
anything weird you're not going to see
like any of the crazy crap you would see
walking down the street in l.a you're
just not going to see it and and dubai
tries very very hard to prevent
degeneracy while also allowing people
from all around the world to come live
in safety
and and and work hard and make a good
life for themselves and they've done it
all under the guise of islam i have so
much respect for that
women everyone's married every woman
obeys her husband every single woman has
four or five six kids big families all
the things we're talking about all the
problems we have here right they've got
none of that none of it because of islam
islam keeps society in the role where
women obey their men
women have children women have big
families women are exceptionally happy
to do so yes before before some western
girl comes in here and runs their mouth
the islamic women are happier than any
you're going to see in the club tonight
and they're very true they're happy
society is functioning their population
is growing because in most western
countries the population is declining
yep tim talking about it today i'm
talking about we're showing we'll have
one kid
doesn't work it doesn't work right do
you two people need to have 3.1 kids
because people die right people die
prematurely blah blah blah
so we have population problems in the
west they have none of the population
problems society is functioning and
that's that's what society is society is
society you start to the smallest
possible group you have families and
families make a street and that street
makes a village and that village makes a
town that town makes a city and that
city makes a country
that's a beautiful uh
example that you just gave but we seem
like people are going away from
from this
uh you gave this example how the there's
like a
hierarchy you have the the husband
running the house then the the wife and
there's some structure there and people
are having children we see a lot of
people walking dogs over here
yeah well i mean not nothing against
dogs i'm not saying but you seem like
people have replaced
are taking more pets than children
nowadays yeah absolutely and and there's
a bunch of reasons for that and it's
basically because i think most both
genders especially in the west have
forgotten their roles as a whole like i
i understand why most men are not waking
up thinking you know what i want to have
a bunch of kids with a woman the legal
system's out to destroy you most the
women aren't going to behave themselves
or comply in any kind of manner
like i had many muslim friends i grew up
in in lieutenant england which is
predominantly muslim and england as a
whole london has a lot of muslims as
well yeah my muslims friends used to say
to me all the time we'd be out and we'd
be walking around and they'd see some
girl in a short skirt or whatever and
they say this is why i need an islamic
wife is she a wife she's naked and drunk
at 2 pm
like there's there's
did you mean 2 a.m or 2 p.m actually p.m
sorry 2 p.m
2 p.m in the afternoon wow just drunk
and just you know running around acting
crazy and
and and there's a there's a degree of
i mean hey i think if you were to ask
any man if you'd want an islamic wife a
wife who complies who's not going to
cheat who behaves herself who dresses
modestly maybe not even completely you
know full burka but dresses modestly
behaves appropriately shows respect this
that was that whole podcast was about
how to try and make females basically
act the way they've acted for the
longest period of human history up until
modern times where they've completely
forgotten and i said well islam fixes it
because they don't have any of these
problems right we we now live in a world
in the west where we've thrown religion
away and we've thrown cultural norms
away we've thrown so many things away
and there's a degree of
confusion amongst people people are lost
they really are men and women i think a
lot of the western women act so
degenerate and they don't do it because
they're
evil they're doing it because they're
trying to find happiness
and they can't find it right and they
think oh maybe a new man's happiness
maybe drinking alcohol's happiness maybe
taking drugs is happiness that and if
you don't ever find a higher purpose
you're just going to degenerate in a
spiral downwards and that's kind of
what's happened and now we're in a
situation where in the west a man can't
find a wife worth having
and people keep saying oh men don't want
to be men anymore men don't want to get
married would you marry some chick you
meet in the club in miami
you'd be a fool like i won't you know so
it's yeah it's really interesting how
society's degraded and it's all started
at the bottom i it's very hard to find a
humble woman who's modest who wants to
have many many children for a man she
obeys and respects in the western world
outside of
islam his family levels broken that it's
broken the whole way up yup yup and
that's what's happened in the west and
the first world islamic countries have
none of those problems so if you're
going to talk about a belief system that
fixes issues
you need to go to islam
even though i wouldn't identify as a
muslim i have sue i have absolute
respect for the ideology respect for the
mentality respect for the warrior aspect
of it i respect them they don't play
they don't play you can't solve their
[ __ ] but you can insult the church all
day you can make fun of the
show
true again no
yeah
and there's a there's a lot of depth to
what you're saying absolutely yeah and
what's the point of a belief system if
it doesn't maintain society like we're
talk i just said there how islam will
fix a lot of the problems of society
well what's the point of a belief system
if it doesn't maintain society wasn't
that the whole point of belief systems
since the dawn of time wasn't it to show
people how to live in a way which is
going to benefit the world as a whole
isn't that the whole point of a belief
system if you have a belief system that
doesn't benefit society then what then
what what's the what good is it right
christianity ain't benefiting society
anymore because no one's listening
christianity's so weak which goes on to
the point i'm just about to make about
how you cannot insult
the islamic faith you cannot insult it
you cannot mock it
in in the christian countries
they mock christianity all day long
they'll make fun of their own religion
it's it's it's incredible right and it's
to the point now
where it on netflix on tv they'll just
market market market but they still even
in these countries which see themselves
as atheists or agnostic will not mock
the islamic religion because they know
that that's going to be a mistake
and this goes on to a wider point
outside of religion which is kind of my
life philosophy if you don't have the
balls to fight and defend an idea then
you don't have an idea
it doesn't matter what you think if
someone comes along and says it's not
true i apologize for swearing if someone
comes along and says we'll beep it out
if someone comes along and says that's
not true and you're not prepared to
stick up for yourself and defend your
idea then it doesn't matter anymore if i
say two plus two is four and someone
comes along and says two plus two is
five and he's about to hit me and i'm
scared of him then he becomes right
might makes right to a degree if you're
not prepared to defend an idea you don't
have an idea so if you're not prepared
to defend the faith you don't have a
faith
and that's why when you start to add all
these things up it's like the last faith
on the planet is is islam there's no
other faith that people are ready to die
for and defend and if you're not ready
to defend an idea you don't have an idea
at all
and for those people who are tuning in
who are not acquainted there's a lot of
a lot of people who are muslim watching
this program but we get a lot of not yet
muslims out there and islam simply means
to gain peace to acquire peace
uh purpose in life by submitting your
will to the one creator of the heavens
and earth god almighty in arabic we say
allah and there make the language jesus
spoke he would say allah aloh this is uh
you know simply the one creator that
heavens on earth now you um you
mentioned in one of your talks you talk
about will smith and some of um
the things that he's been through you
know with his marriage and that do you
think he could have benefited from the
from the system the way of of this way
of life we're talking about absolutely
he could have i mean look look at the
absolute
he's become a laughingstock he was the
coolest guy in the world right everyone
loved will smith before his wife
completely destroyed him and wrecked him
it's it's it's really crazy to me
because we live in a world now where you
have to be a a real
i want to use the correct language here
you have to be an animal as a man and i
mean you have to be like a real top
shelf top tier man to make sure that you
can get through life in the western
world without either being embarrassed
by a female cheated on by a female to
still enjoy the company of females to
not have anyone try and take you to
court or destroy you like if if you're
the top top one percent like i've i've
done fine then you can do it right but
for the for the average man in the west
outside of the idea of an islamic
marriage for example there's basically
no hope there's no hope like
what are you going to do what are you
going to pull off it's incredible and
and i know a bunch of guys who who are
christian and they go to the church and
their christian wives cheat on them like
the church ain't going to save you it's
this is what i mean like
there's no there's no faith there's
nothing there
and it's kind of yeah it's incredible
and you like you say you talk about will
smith i think a lot of people can
benefit from the entire islamic
world view i think it's i think it's
beneficial to society as a whole and we
look at if you want to look at countries
i'd love to actually do this study maybe
you know better than me but if you were
to look at countries in terms of police
expenditure to crime
i would i would guarantee that the
islamic countries the ones we just
talked about the first world ones are
some of the safest countries on earth
per capita for the amount of money they
spend trying to police crime whereas in
other countries we're just spending
unlimited money trying to stop crime we
can't stop women don't respect men
anymore men don't really want the women
besides for a one-night stand no one's
having children no one's having families
no one's satisfied or fulfilled which is
why they want to take drugs and do
stupid things and degenerate themselves
and everything spirals into the other
right humans need higher purpose
and and this is the thing i'll be
completely honest with you my friend i
was an atheist for a long time
i i really was i was an atheist for a
long time and i i didn't truly really
believe in god until about maybe seven
eight years ago i thought i was a smart
ass and thought i was you know atheist
blah blah blah and then
god starts showing himself to me in many
ways whichever religion he's from but
then i realized that people need
something to believe in all these people
who are
atheist
they're they're they believe in climate
change and abortion law and kovid more
than anybody else they have their
beliefs they have their religions
liberalism and their religion is a
religion of absolute degeneracy you know
like look at the things they purport
look at how hard they tried to convince
the world that it's a good idea that we
eat the bugs and and climate change and
that people change gender and all this
other garbage so everyone needs
something higher to believe in and i
think that these
i mean i correct me if i'm wrong
islam is not even as old as christianity
right it's not even that old is it
well it goes a little deeper if i can
just take a second and kind of
run it down to you see what we believe
is that you have the first man adam and
he was told to submit his will
to the creator alone without associates
not to worship a stick of stone a bone
or anything creation so we believe that
islam started with the first man adam
then that concept of submission to the
will of one and only one god not
worshiping your desires not worshiping a
human being
anything in creation was the same way of
life that was preached and teached
with every messenger that god almighty
sent and
from abraham noah moses you name it all
many of the biblical prophets they all
call their people to worship one and
only one god and to submit their will
like the lord's prayer you hear the
lord's prayer oh our father who in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done we say this is
islam
so just like at that time if abraham was
asked if he ever heard this term human
he was a human but he never heard the
human
that term human uh but now
if
if he was a human he was same thing if
you there's a verse in the quran where
god almighty is saying abraham abraham
he wasn't a jew or a christian but he
was one who submitted his will to god
almighty that's what a muslim is because
people get that's why uh these defining
these terms is so important because
you know you're sitting muslim you think
an arab in the desert you'll think islam
it's like some religion just it's a new
religion that started with muhammad no
no we say it started with the first man
adam it continued with moses abraham
jesus peace be upon him they all called
people to islam to submit your will to
the will of god and they were all
muslims they were all ones who submitted
their will to one and only one god you
know it's a simple it's very simple to
understand very very you know and then
when you mention uh god
it's it goes with the innate nature
there's a beautiful verse in the quran
where it's uh it's 112th chapter where
he says kulhu allah
the the unique the eternal he begets not
nor is he begotten meaning that he's not
born of of anyone nor does he die he
doesn't have children a dna of zip code
an area code no uh and there's nothing
comparable to him nothing nothing if you
you cannot compare anyone or anything to
god this is the pure monotheism this is
what distinguishes islam for every other
ism is the pure monotheism
so i hope i answered your question so we
say it's not a new religion started with
muhammad it's just the finality he was
just the final messenger
and completing it with the the living
miracle that we have today which is the
quran because jesus at his time to prove
he was a messenger he did certain
miracles uh and but if you were to ask
an atheist today show me those miracles
you couldn't show them uh but we believe
in them but today anyone who takes a
scientific analytical approach they will
see from the preservation of the quran
to the prophecies you know to many of
the scientific state there's you know
the the literary miracle of the quran
you know there's just too many things
that it doesn't add up that this would
come from a human just a human being so
it's not blind faith in islam you take
you use the faculties that god almighty
gave you you look into the quran you
look into the life of prophet muhammad
and then like myself and many you're
like
this is not possible this can come from
a human being and then you submit do you
have a lot of christians who who convert
or change do you have that a lot because
you can go and watch you know i got
hundreds i've been doing this since uh
early 2000 we got hundreds and hundreds
of uh programs with people
i have a good friend he's from romania
he's uh
gibril romani gabriel romani uh he's
somebody who was a a christian and he
accepted islam you have tons of tons of
tons of stories of people same thing who
are struggling with with many of the
concepts of god that are out there and
and then they looked into they looked
into all the different different
religions like myself
and they saw that islam just made the
most sense like you're saying the things
that it fixed the problems you know of
society it gave solutions not only on
how to go to the from the smallest
things from how to go to the bathroom to
how to run your home and how to run a
country everything is laid out and it
doesn't make sense that this human being
could have came up with these things you
know yeah it's true it's absolutely it's
absolutely interesting and that's where
the base of my faith comes from my my
respect for it all tell me tell me this
you said if we remove all the garbage in
the fairy tales if men are true to their
biology no man is a one woman man
i truly actually believe that i believe
if you a lot of i think that obviously
okay we're humans right we exist as
biological animals and then we exist
with the degree of societal programming
and i think the fem-centric societies of
the west have convinced men
that we should have one woman and one
woman only and i can get conspiracy
theorists on why that is but i think a
lot of it is down to the fact that they
are trying very hard in the western
world to suppress the will of man they
want the western male to a degree to be
suppressed and not suppressed in a way
which empowers him because i think
there's different degrees of suppression
right you can be suppressed in a way
which will empower you but you can also
be suppressed in a way which will just
destroy your will to fight
and i think a lot of that is down to not
not down to this but every single thing
they do every single thing society
purports to a degree is not to empower
men
and you're more likely to feel powerful
as a man if you have
three wives or if you have a lot of a
female who adore you right but if you
have one chick who doesn't obey you who
you can't divorce without losing the
house who won't even have sex with you
and doesn't want to have your kids and
you're stuck with her it's pretty hard
to find warrior spirit it's hard to act
like a king if you don't feel like a
king in your own household and i think
that if you were to go to any man on in
the world and be honest with him and say
look
uh it's perfectly acceptable for you to
have this woman she's going to be loyal
to you she's going to love you she's
gonna stay with you she's your wife and
you can also have this one and she's
gonna be your wife same deal i do not
think there's a man alive who would say
no to that i really don't why would he
why would he right i think society tells
us we're supposed to only have one but
i i understand in islam you can have
four i think i but i'm not an expert you
are but um
i just think it's natural human nature
to enjoy the company more than one
female or i think if you're a
a man of means you could easily have
more than one wife i think that's
perfectly normal and i think that's been
beaten out of the western mail as a
suppression mechanism inshallah god
willing when you do take your your
shahada which is simply a testimony that
there's again that's like in the uh then
when you were listening to it you were
in your car that simple statement that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
allah and muhammad is messenger so
inshallah when you take your shahada do
you see yourself
being someone
that would need four wives because
somebody in your state is that something
where now this uh this if you want to be
someone who's devoted to god hundred
percent and now it's in marriage and now
god is giving you an avenue is this also
another proof because i actually if i
have christians come to me and say you
know what eddie you know scratching your
head i had one professor of jiu jitsu i
teach
brazilian jiu-jitsu great jiu-jitsu and
friend of mine he's we're on the mats
together and out of nowhere he comes to
me and says eddie you know what i've
been thinking about this he goes you
know it makes sense that man can have
more one wife there's more women you
know and this that and the other he's
using his logic and just he just uh i
don't know where he came up with it but
you know what else more than one wife
will give you it'll give you children
faster like dude like because because
even the even the most
atheistic or or the the most christian
men i know they might have two or three
babies and it'll take five to six years
by the time the woman gets pregnant et
cetera et cetera blah blah blah and they
said i'd love to have more kids my
wife's finished now etc
look if you're a man of means
financially let's say me for example i'm
i'm financially very well off i'd love
to have 10 children i can't get that
from one woman maybe okay maybe i could
right but you understand the point right
so there's there's also a bunch of other
benefits to having four wives just just
have a nice big large family i mean why
be a man this is why you're on the
planet right you're on the planet to
spread your genes and spread your ideas
and to to conquer the best you can it's
inside of every single male we all have
that natural
instinct inside of us the masculine
insect an instinct for conquest that's
why we went to war like we did since the
dawn of human time right you want to
have a nice you want to be old on your
rocking chair and look down at all your
children who obey you and you want to be
proud with what you've done and yeah
having a bunch of wives makes a whole
bunch of sense
it makes a bunch of sense like i don't
see why they wouldn't now obviously the
western female will say that's
disgusting but the western female will
sleep with the guy she met for 10
minutes and she thinks that's not
disgusting so her entire worldview is
absolutely distorted i don't think
there's anything wrong with with with
many women sharing a man who has the
means to take care of them and provide
for them i think that's completely
natural many people they you know they
twist this and they think this is like
some harem of a muslim with all these
women and whatnot they get this
hollywood image or whatnot but you know
when people this is a woman's actual
right you know a woman to choose the
best man out there to go ahead you know
when there's also
uh you look in in today's society where
like you're saying you know you know
it's it's hard to also have a a strong
family this is a responsibility this is
not just something where you're just
playing with them you're taking her on
you're caring for her you know not every
man can do this it takes a man to do
this and many you know you talk about
this also the difference between and
fill us in what's a beta male alpha male
and woman you know the hypergamy women
looking for the the best men out there
and a lot of them you also talk about
men have turned into cowards you know
what i mean so
uh it's it's a role that is it's hard to
fulfill but for someone like you who now
you know and somebody let's say who's
used to who's in who's in who is used to
let's say a famous person a celebrity a
man of status and and you also give this
example like through history the sultans
the the leaders the the uh the congress
whoever the the highest men of society
this was something that they all had uh
multiple wives you know they had
multiple women so now to limit a man in
this stature and the status to just one
but now you have an avenue that god has
allowed what do you say but this this is
the exact point right this is why a lot
of the degeneracy that exists amongst
western world leadership exists like if
you look at rich men in the west right a
rich man in the west
especially a political someone who works
in politics they're only allowed by
society and by a christian law to have
one woman and they have this one woman
and they're not satisfied with her so
what do they end up doing they end up
looking for secrets they want to do
things that nobody's going gonna know
about so what do they do in secret well
we can go down the the rabbit hole of of
epstein's island and xyz and all the
crazy degenerate disgusting things they
do just to pretend and and
you know promote this one woman image
but truthfully no man is satisfied with
that and when cuz they're not satisfied
they're out there doing whatever they
can in secret and basically a lot of
it's absolutely degenerate whereas if
you look at the leader of uae he has
seven eight wives but that means he
doesn't need to go down any kind of
degenerate avenue because he's satisfied
as an individual and he's satisfied with
his status look as a man especially if
you're a high status male you want to be
satisfied with that status right i have
worked very very hard to become a high
status male so i want to drive a car
that reflects that i want to have a
relationship or relationships that
reflect that nobody wants to become the
richest man in the world to sit around
with one chick who doesn't obey them
nobody's interested in that and that's
why they go down the path of degeneracy
that's why i think the western world is
so degenerate because they're not
allowed to live out their natural male
in instinct they're not allowed to live
out their masculine instinct even if you
look at let's say a country which is
still christian but is not bound by the
same societal rules if you look at let's
say russia right
every rich man in russia every oligarch
he has a wife but he has
sorry he has five 19 year old
girlfriends and society's fine so
there's no epstein's island there's no
you know hunter biden's laptop and
cracked out prostitutes and all this
insanity and all that just basically
comes down to the fact that they've told
rich powerful man men they're allowed
one woman only and they end up just
going down a path of secrecy and
degeneracy to try and feel satisfied and
that's another thing that islam fixes
because you can be a man of stature a
rich powerful man have four wives that
reflect that and i think four wives are
probably about enough for any guy so
you'll be okay you're not gonna start
running around the world doing insane
insane things that that that's the limit
there for four wives uh
so tell me then
just since you mentioned ukraine that's
another example if all the men go out
because you know you have this this
whole movement with the feminism
and now the men are the ones who are
stepping up going out and getting killed
in the war and now let's say you have an
abundance of women doesn't this solves
the problem no
absolutely it does yeah and it's i mean
the whole feminism argument is amazing
how quickly that disappears when war
starts right so that that's out the
window but yeah it does fix the problem
um and and also
it's kind of sad like
i live in romania which is next door to
ukraine and since the war started i get
i'm getting a lot of messages from girls
who live in ukraine trying to
come visit come live with me in romania
effectively kind of run away to a degree
and it's kind of sad like imagine being
a man in a trench in the freezing cold
to defend the country
and then the most beautiful women of
your country are just trying to use
instagram to bounce to some millionaires
house like
i don't know man the whole dynamic is is
kind of scary to me
i i really
and that's another thing like
when we talk we go back a point not to
not to over iterate but to go back to
what we're talking about earlier about
how you cannot disrespect the islamic
faith i understand and respect the
people even all the wars that happened
in the world it makes so much more sense
to me to fight for an idea or a religion
or a faith than it ever would be to
fight for a country for example i don't
think i don't think there's any country
on earth worth believing in i do think
it's worth believing in god i don't
think it's worth believing in any
country i think it's probably the only
thing worth fighting for in defending uh
if i was ukrainian i would not be
interested in defending ukraine as a
sovereign state because i know too much
about politics and corruption and how it
all works and i understand the world too
well to go get blown up for no reason
you know so
it's another thing that's interesting so
yeah it's it's certainly an interesting
world but when you when you take
religion or faith as a whole out of the
world there's very little left but just
degeneracy
hedonism
corruption on every level
and then what's your life purpose right
what are you trying to do okay
you're trying to have a bunch of kids
maybe that's probably the most noble
thing you could do but if you're gonna
do that without any kind of religious
framework to install it and without any
kind of faith for them to grow up under
then who are they gonna become are they
just going to become people who consume
netflix and and new slaves to the to the
new world order is that what you want is
that why you want to have children so
they can be raised by
a school system which teaches them to
hate you
it's like you remove you remove faith
and remove religion from from from your
life
there's nothing else out here what are
you gonna do eat star drink starbucks
every day and get rich to buy a new ipad
like is that gonna satisfy you
it's kind of crazy to me and this is
coming from someone who was an atheist
and i i talked to atheists now and and i
say to him why are you alive what are
you living for and their answer is
always
fail fail to impress me let's leave it
at that
wow
tell me what's the difference quickly
before i go to my next question and i
got a i got a surprise for you i got a
guest that just came into town and he's
somebody also who you can learn a lot
from you can watch some of his videos
very well known out there his name is uh
naman ali khan and you'll see him he
just walked into the studio i just
coincidenced that i got you now
and he's an expert actually
in the subject of quran right that we
touched upon a little bit so uh he'll i
like him to just come in and ask her ask
a question or two but he's here next he
just walked in actually then we just
came to the studio but uh tell what's
the difference when you talk about talk
about for these terms in my generation
we didn't really hear much of these
terms like beta male alpha male what's
the difference between a beta and alpha
what is it for the for you know someone
like my father never heard these terms
how would you define it but he knows
he'll know when you talk when you
describe it what that is
yeah it's actually quite hard to define
i think it's because it's over it's can
be overused and it can be largely
misunderstood but i think if i had to
try and break it down to the most base
level i think an alpha male is a man
that other men want to be
um and i think a beta male is that of as
a man other men are not trying to
emulate any degree right there's if you
put 100 men in a room there's it's very
easy to point to the five or six men
every man wishes they was or would like
to be more like and i think that's what
an alpha male is and i think women can
detect that you know uh even better than
anyone else because they're
instinctually driven to detect that so
that's what i'd say an alpha male is and
i'd say a beta male is somebody who does
not have those qualities so nobody looks
at him and goes i want to be more like
him or i want to know what he knows or i
want to live like he lives
uh you you talk about
the father should be a superhero
you know to to these children but he's
turned into uh kind of like uh wha what
did you say
yeah i mean but
it was my father was a superhero right i
was raised in a way in which i really
viewed my father as a superhero but that
was also based on the fact that he did
not
submit to the will of my mother right if
you have a man who's scared of his wife
can he truly be a superhero in any
regard and that's a question i don't
know
i don't think so i can't imagine a man
who's scared of his wife acting like a
superhero because women have completely
different life goals and instincts to
men this is something that most people
forget and don't understand i have it
all the time
i get a chick or whatever and she says i
wish you didn't work so much why are you
always busy why are you always working
the fact that i'm always busy and always
working is the reason you were attracted
to me in the first place but now that
you have me you're going to pretend i
shouldn't be doing those things you're
going to try and change me now you want
me to stop working right that's the only
reason we even that's the only reason
you were even attracted to me in the
first place
it's kind of amazing and if you allow a
female to impose her will on you as a
man no matter what she says about how
it's going to make you better and make
her happier etc it always leads to the
same place which is misery for both
parties you have to be an iron frame you
have to be resilient to the insidious
because it's insidious right they try
very very hard they're very very clever
they cook they cook nice meals they're
warm you know and they're all like you
know baby you don't have to go don't go
gym stay here with me et cetera et
cetera and i think that's a very
dangerous path to walk down but i was
lucky to live to grow up in a household
where my father never ever ever listened
to my mother not a disrespectful way
just in a very much like okay thanks for
talking i've i appreciate your point of
view but no
so
that's who he was right what would you
say to him is one proof
that he can look at to to confirm that
islam is the quran is not a man-made
book and islam is not a man-made
religion is beat from the divine being
an expert in the quran
well um
lots can be said um i'd start off by my
own journey to share can you hear him a
couple of things can you hear them
andrew yeah okay
nice talking to you uh i think that i
what i like to do uh when i meet with
audiences
uh professors of other faiths and you
know intellectuals anybody uh is that
i'd like to invite them to explore the
quran
you know intellectually
and critically
that's an invitation that the quran
gives
it's interesting that people perceive
religion as something that you have to
be indoctrinated into
and you have to follow it as the
dictates are and you don't have to
actually critically ask any questions or
think and contemplate and the quran
is kind of unique in the way that it
presents its message because it's
constantly saying don't you then think
don't you contemplate haven't you asked
questions this is a book for those who
seek to ask to have answers
it's not actually asking you to shut
your brain off and accept what it's
saying it's actually asking you to
contemplate its message so it stands
really unique in that sense
my own you know
since it offered that invitation to me i
didn't come to the quran first as
someone who believes in it i
wanted to figure this thing out and you
know trying to make sense of it
and
many of the things that i struggled with
in philosophy when i was a student of
philosophy
they started getting unraveled as i was
getting deeper and deeper in my study of
the quran it just started kind of
untying a lot of those knots and it's
also remarkable that
some of the biggest addictions that
people suffer from
every one of them is targeted one after
the other in the quran
right some of the things that plague
humanity more like gambling for example
alcohol for example intoxication for
example like
each of these things is targeted and you
think
it's not just of solving a muslim
problem it's solving a human problem
it's solving a societal problem and
solving a global problem by targeting
these each of these specific things
the other thing that i would that
really fascinated me i ended up writing
a book on it ended up getting taught
around the world alhamdulillah it's even
being used
in one of the islamic studies courses at
harvard now uh is divine speech it's a
book i dedicated along with my student
to why is this why is this book why am i
believing that it's divine what's making
me think this and i wrote it for a
non-muslim audience actually
it's a little bit academic but the point
of it was there are there are elements
to this book
and the way that it's structured that if
you first if you went to the library or
you
got on amazon and bought yourself a
translation of the quran you started
reading it
you think the subject is kind of going
all over the place right it's it's it's
not staying on the same subject right
it's saying some profound things but the
organization seems unlike anything i've
ever read
and that was one of the things that
baffled me at first like why is it
organized in this way
and so i one of the areas of my study
became the organization of the quran why
is it organized in this way why is god
talking in this disarray and what i
discovered was something absolutely
breathtaking
that it's it's got a symmetrical
structure
that you'll have a chapter for example
that's hundreds of verses like bakkala
is 286 verses it's an oral tradition so
it wasn't written first it was recited
and pronounced and memorized in that way
amounts to about 50 pages in arabic
right
but if you study the subject matter
the the the nine subjects that are
occurring in this long
50 page discourse
are like subject one is directly tied to
subject nine and two to eight and three
to seven and four to six and five right
center in the middle like there's an
incredible three-dimensional structure
to the way the arguments being presented
human beings we think linear right i'm
going to make point a then i'm going to
make point b then i'm going to make
point c that's how i organize my
thoughts
and unless you write something down and
say you know what i'm going to do this
and just for fun i'm going to do abc and
then go cba
right even doing that in in six
sentences is hard for me as i'm sitting
here talking to you because my brain
isn't wired that way but this
thousand you know a millennium and a
half old tradition has got multiple
surahs and multiple chapters
where this kind of a structure is
demonstrated over and over again and
other kinds of structures are like this
is not possible for a human being to do
linguistically it's not possible i'm a
student of linguistics it's just not
possible these kinds of structures this
kind of organization that that's one of
the things i wrote about in the book and
i started ended up teaching courses on
this stuff
um
but for just uh just take a step back
level my invitation to anybody is put
your preconceived notions aside take
what you may have heard about islam what
you may have thought about it from your
own faith traditions point of view put
all of that aside and you i wouldn't
even invite somebody to read the quran
to accept islam read the quran
neutrally and get a first
you know an unbiased impression
and i would think it's really difficult
to not walk away truly being moved
by what you're what you're being exposed
to truly being hit by what you're
exposed to
uh the the final thing i'll say is there
is a huge
tragedy in the world today that even
most muslims aren't as aware of the
quran as they should be
right so muslims don't become a really
good representation of
the contents of the book right so even
disconnecting yourself from the muslim
bias i'm just going to read this for
myself
with no other influences as much as
possible at the end of the day human
beings can
are going to have some bias or the other
but as much as i can consciously be
disconnected from bias and give it a
shot
and read it i think that that would be
my invitation to anybody
andrew any question any uh final
question anything you'd like to ask him
why he's here what happened was because
we got delayed with the program he next
guest was coming in so i'm with you
but this is amazing you can look him up
actually online
and you'll see a ton of his videos i'm
going to i'm going to read that book as
well because it was really interesting
what you were saying it was really
interesting after the show i'd like to
send you a copy as a gift and also your
invitation is exactly the way i would
have done it anyway i would have read it
i'm going to read it i've yet to read
the quran but it's certainly something
i'm going to do i'm going to read it
without a preconceived notion without a
preconceived idea and i think that's the
best way to do things because you're
right there's too much bias in the world
but um from from what i know i think we
just talked about for the last hour from
what i know i have absolute respect for
the religion and respect for the faith
and i've been very
very blessed to be on the show so thank
you very much for having me i appreciate
it thank you thank you very so you're
i'm from chicago from chicago also this
is your hometown do you visit chicago at
all you plan on visiting anytime i'll be
honest with you not too often i i if i
do come through i'll i'll hit you up i
am
i'm i'm politically opposed to the usa i
try to avoid it or or you know what you
got your private jet so when i go to
bosnia i mean you could fly can you fly
into bosnia yeah i can absolutely i can
come i can never mind my kickboxing
coach was bosnian as well yeah what was
his name
i don't know how he says
yeah i know mostly i know most of the
the top guys over there the kickboxers
and everything would be they'd love to
so you but you never visited bosnia did
you ever
visit i've yet to visit but i've heard
it's an absolutely beautiful place and
and the bosnian people are some of the
most resilient
dangerous they're the bosnian people you
don't want to mess with the bosnians
would you ever consider taking a trip
how long is the plane ride from romania
to bosnia uh hour hour and a half so far
yeah how about if i get your invitation
you come down is it possible how much
advanced notice would you need let's
keep talking about it let's do it
sometime this summer for sure bro let's
do it okay it was honor very nice
talking with you brother thank you my
friend all right thank you god bless you
all right peace call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum